Le BAPE croit que le Québec doit
adopter une approche plus
musclée.Normand Grondin.
- Nos sites d'enfouissement sont
on prévoit en ouvrir
d'autres et, selon le rapport
du BAPE, les objectifs actuels
de réduction des déchets
sont carrément inatteignables.Je
la commission d'enquête, BAPE
- Que ce soit le ministère detex
mêmes résultats. Ça sera...
c'est unambitieux qui
ne pourrait pas être atteint.
- Chaque Québécois produit
724 kilos de matières
et le gouvernement
souhaitait abaisser ce seuil
ilos d'ici 2023.
Comme ça semble impossible,
le BAPE propose un changement
radical d'approche : consommermt
réduire les déchets à la source.
- Nous pensons que la société
se est prête à consacrer
les énery compris financières, r
l'amélioration de la gestion
des matières résiduelles.
est bien reçue par
les environnementalistes.
KAREL MÉNARD, Front commun pour
la gestion écolo. des déchets
- Ce que peut-êtr peut-êtr peutr
de travailler sur des nouvelles
gies ou des nouvelles
façons de faire au niveau
de la gestion des déchets
comment comment comment comment;
comment éviter un problèmeplutôr
des solutions à un problème.
- Le volumineux rapport
nombreuses pistes de solutions :
produits durables et réparables,
économie circulaire, taxes,
AMÉLIE CÔTÉ, analyste enréductÉe
- Les commissaires proposent
plusieurs mesures
d'écofiscalité, d'augmenter
les coûts d'enfou
aussi, pour s'assurer que
l'élimination coûte plus cher
Donc, vraiment, ce
des solutions très concrètes.
- Recyc-Québec...vernement, on e
de revoir en profondeur
le mandat de l'organisme
Recyc-Québec et, surtout,
plus coercitives pour
les contrevenants.
- C'est pas avec des gestes
individuels qu'on va réussir
des contraintes réglementaires
et législatives. E
le ministère qui a le pouvoir
d'adopter ces modifications-là,
- En matière de gestion
des mati
la performance du Québec
est en recul constant
qu'il s'est fixés en 2015.
in,
Radio-Canada, Mon